this is from John Jacob J my hi Miss
Smith my name whenever I go out the
people are Lisa hey sometimes I think
I'm saying what everybody watches the
saying which is what would
[Music]
hey BuzzFeed hey you like BuzzFeed
I love BuzzFeed I got some friends that
work off the wait wait we got stop we
need to introduce ourselves we're
assuming that these people know who we
are
introduce yourself first I'm Tiffany
Haddish that's right and I am me Kevin
Hart
and we are about to do some thirst weeks
yeah and I'm gonna read all of Kevin's
thirst weeks that's right what they
saying about you oh you go first go okay
I'm excited but I wanna touch ik Kevin
Hart real ants okay well that's not bad
honey Moses nobody can't tell me Kevin
Hart little ass ain't sexy right they
care if they do damn their life then
lime and cheek okay but when did Kevin
Hart becomes that oMG from baby doll oh
and it's even like a daddy when did I
become daddy though daddy is me as a me
dad I'm daddy that's a big Oh a very
long big Kevin Hart look so red pharmacy
well I'm sure to ask for it out of it
Kevin Hart is so tiny and funny and cute
I want to put him in my pocket you know
she's my mother call me a little gummy
bear
forget it I didn't think it through
I know Tiffany don't know Timmy that's a
rabbit now let's see what they said
about you - thirsty jeez - Tiffany
alright Oh at Tiffany hat is so fine
that if I had one slice of pizza left
over after a long night of drinking I
100 thirsty is just showing these shares
but you know if somebody get it to you
then email you or or just mean a day
they were full Tiffany Haddish is one
fine-ass woman my first ever tweet I
rock no no no that's the architect bra
I'm watching this episode of hip hop
squares fainted at Tiffany Haddish to
get all my kids out of me
it said you want to give you that bus
off it's funny that let you have it
Iggy that baby batter I wonder what is
credit oh man this is this is windy
mullennix okay yeah like a Tiffany
Haddish was strangling me I feel like I
would be like this is super fun she
could kick me in the booze and I'd be
having a great time now Wendy yeah
I'll get up I'm not sure y'all should be
sending out nasty tweets all right I'm
sorry
but Tiffany hands are so hot and funny
I'm gay
Tiffany Haddish let me lick that mole
off your face my top that'sit's breath I
don't nobody want to be like a cat
trying to lick your mouth off huh I know
sighs look at mama
I know signs of cannibalism when I see
it this man is trying to eat you wrong
eat me wrong each night and say it I had
a good time tip did you have a good time
yeah have fun give a shot at the
BuzzFeed thank you thank you bad speed
everybody's on BuzzFeed does favor go
see nice cool sin 728 starring myself
Tiffany Haddish and a slew of other
funny comedic actors and actresses it's
a fun movie it's a great time it doesn't
disappoint
yeah you won't say anything else close
there you go
see you soon bye I found I worked very
hard to establish the fact that I'm five
foot in the half close to five five
three five this is called a five five
and to break it down I had a pair of
timberland boots on I'm definitely there
you
[Music]